Christian saintpa la diriez-vous vous
êtes devenus avocat par extraction
est-ce qu'on pourrait le formuler de la
sorte vous n'êtes pas un enfant du
sérail d'ailleurs vous continuez à vous
décrire comme un rural à Paris ah oui
parce que je crois que c'est ce qui me
caractérise beaucoup je pense que j'ai
apporté à Paris des valeurs de la
ruralité et je pense vraiment que nous
devrions nous référer souvent à la
ruralité pour organiser nos vies et
notre groupe social alors par effraction
je revendique quand même d'avoir gagné
ma place de l'avoir sans doute mérité
mais disons que ce n'était pas un destin
tout à fait tracé si on peut paraître
de 2016 à 2021 vous avez présidé
l'Association des avocats pénalistes
pourra l'appareil vous êtes quand même
sacrément bien débrouillé dans les
arcanes du pouvoir en tout cas c'est ma
plus grande fierté
parce que cette association elle a été
créée par des hommes et des femmes que
j'admirais avant de devenir avocat et
puis quand je suis devenu avocat je les
ai fréquentés beaucoup sont devenus mes
amis et ils m'ont élus pour être à la
tête de cette association qui avait été
créée notamment par et qui réunissait
Jean-Yves Leborgne Peltier madame Smadja
Jacqueline Laffont aïkerzog vraiment
comme d'Artagnan vous êtes natif du
verbe mais à défaut de manier l'épée
vous êtes devenus à 20 ans instituteur
avant de faire des études de droit vous
avez toujours eu la défense dans la peau
dès votre plus jeune âge plus qu'un
métier c'est une vocation c'est une
mission
en tout cas je pense que c'est une
nature je pense que les avocats
pénalistes soyez nous nous reconnaissons
nous nous fléons nous sommes très
différents mais je crois que nous
réagissons de la même façon au même
moment devant une injustice et je pense
que dans les cours de récréation nous
étions les uns et les autres des enfants
qui réagissant à l'injustice voilà
pourquoi je parle de nature toujours
cette très grande sensibilité exacerbée
parfois à ce que nous considérons comme
des situations qui ne devraient pas
avoir lieu et ou ne une personne est
stigmat les mises à l'écart et après une
vocation quand j'étais enfant je jouais
à l'avocat mais je veux aussi au curé
pour prendre la parole donc finalement
peut-être que
j'aurais pu mal tourner
[Rires]
c'est ouvert veuillez vous asseoir
il paraît que vous avez été bibronné à
cette émission messieurs les jurés
diffusés sur la deuxième chaîne de la
RTF dès 1974 c'est à cette émission que
vous devez votre vocation ou à Gisèle à
la limite qui défendait le droit à
l'avortement à Bobigny c'est en essayant
de reconstruire les choses que je pense
à ces images qui d'après moi m'ont
beaucoup marqué Gisèle Halimi nous
devons être en 73 à Bobigny et je me
souviens de cette solitude si vous
voulez de cette comme ça que je le
percevais cette réalité c'est une femme
de soutien je pense que je percevais
autour de moi dans ma famille peut-être
une certaine désapprobation ça n'est pas
impossible et je me souviens être
fasciné parce que je considérais être
certains courage la noblesse d'être seul
face à des forces qui se mobilisent
contre vous et alors messieurs les jurés
vous voyez j'avais 10 ans puisque vous
montrez cet épisode oui c'était une
émission que je regardais je crois que
j'étais j'ai toujours été c'est marqué
par la solennité
le silence nous les avocats nous sommes
des bavards mais je suis très attaché au
silence et voyez la cour silence maître
vous avez la parole c'est un moment très
très fort dans nos vies professionnelles
mettre vous avez la parole le silence se
fait avant que vous le meubiez ces
silences vont toujours fascinés vous
avez commencé dans le droit de la
copropriété des baux commerciaux et il
vous est arrivé de plaider dans des
cuisines au milieu des champs et même
sur un capot de voiture
exact alors ça c'est le droit de ça
c'est le droit de l'expropriation et
quand on plaide de l'ex-propriation pour
fixer l'indemnité on se rend sur place
et donc aujourd'hui absolument c'est la
procédure qui le veut ainsi et lorsque
une maison est expropriée pour un
ouvrage public pour faire passer une
autoroute mais vous arrivez chez les
gens vous visitez la maison avec le juge
et ensuite parce que nous n'avions pas
le temps d'aller au tribunal par exemple
alors on pouvait s'installer autour de
la table de la cuisine on vient nous
plaît donc on plaide aujourd'hui donc
j'ai plaidé parfois au milieu d'un champ
parce que c'était une propriété agricole
qui était expropriée nous mesurions pour
savoir où étaient les canalisations
d'eau pour savoir si le terrain était
constructible alors ça pour un jeune
c'est très très fort ma sœur aujourd'hui
comme ça sur place absolument sur le
terrain alors en principe on rejoint le
tribunal mais par commodité si ça peut
convenir à tout le monde pour éviter de
revenir 15 jours après puisque nous
l'avons déjà fait et nous avons déjà
échangé nos arguments devant le juge en
botte et en plein et on peut conférer
une solennité quand même on réinvestit
le champ judiciaire en se disant
maintenant nous prenons nos rôles et
nous faisons les choses comme il le faut
alors un métier une carrière c'est bien
sûr le fruit de hasard est aussi de
rencontres celle en 1995 avec le
pénaliste Jean-Yves Leborgne a été
déterminante c'est lui qui vous a ouvert
les portes du pénal
bien sûr sachant que le Borgne
vous l'aimez
maintenant un ami vous savez que c'était
mon patron il m'a offert de devenir son
associé vous savez ça n'est pas rien
comme démarche et nous avons cheminé
ensemble lui il m'apprenant je crois
tout ce que je sais c'est un des plus
grands avocats et même quand je le dis
je dis pas le dire parce que tout de
suite si je dis c'est un des plus grands
avocats français il va me dire mais qui
sont donc les autres donc
certains le sort non mais là je te le
dis très amicalement bien sûr parce que
il pourrait le dire quels sont donc les
autres parce que c'est un des plus
grands avocats français et surtout une
générosité extraordinaire un pénaliste
comme il en existe très peu une culture
extraordinaire donc je l'ai rejoint en
1995 il m'a proposé de une association
en 2000 et nous sommes toujours ensemble
couple qui cheminent ensemble en 2004
vous êtes désigné Christian Saint Palais
pour être l'avocat de Romain Dupuis un
jeune schizophrène responsable du
meurtre de deux infirmières à l'hôpital
électrique de peau de là c'est noué
d'ailleurs la question de la
responsabilité pénale des malades
psychiatriques cette affaire racontez
vous vous allez longtemps tarauder
pourquoi
bon d'abord c'était une affaire dont on
se souvient peut-être un garçon qui
avait tué deux infirmières une
infirmière une aide-soignante et qui
avait décapité l'une des deux donc
c'était une attaque avec une émotion
considérable et on savait que ce garçon
était atteint d'une maladie
psychiatrique qui avait aboli son
discernement et notre code de
prévoit que l'homme qui a commis un
crime quel qu'en soit la gravité mais
dont le discernement était aboli ne peut
pas être condamné alors il y a eu une
polémique le président à ce moment-là
était Nicolas Sarkozy et qui soutenait
que si on prononçait un non-lieu
c'est-à-dire il n'y a plus lieu à
poursuivre les investigations disait-il
ça veut dire que ça n'a pas eu lieu ce
qui est vraiment une aberration pour un
juriste mais donc il y avait une
certaine polémique donc c'est un dossier
qui m'a préoccupé parce que la question
que se pose toujours l'avocat serais-je
à la hauteur pour convaincre de ce que
je considère être juste dans cette
défense là et dans le traitement de ce
dossier là serais-je à la hauteur et
puis ensuite ce qui peut tarauder c'est
que ce garçon comme vous le savez
peut-être est toujours aujourd'hui un
hôpital psy
la question qui se pose est celle de
savoir si la crainte qui avait suscité
ce crime à ce moment-là ne perturbe pas
l'analyse qui est faite sur sa situation
et de savoir aujourd'hui des confrères
ont pris le combat pour sa liberté le
même en multipliant les recours en
exhortant les juges à examiner
sereinement sa situation et alors ce qui
me préoccupe bien sûr c'est qu'on ne lui
réserve pas le sort qu'il mériterait de
connaître parce que l'hospitalisation
par contrainte c'est aussi une situation
très difficile à vivre cette affaire
vous a aussi amené racontez vous à vous
questionner sur votre relation aux
médias et aux clients en quoi a-t-elle
été un détonateur c'est une affaire qui
a été très médiatisée et que
pouvons-nous dire
la question de l'avocat aussi donc il
faut bien dire qu'il se préoccupe aussi
d'être choisi d'être désigné par les
clients il y a une affaire médiatique
lui permet une certaine exposition
qui lui permet d'être connu c'est une
préoccupation que l'on peut admirer il y
a les grands principes et puis il y a
aussi la réalité du quotidien et la
nécessité d'être connue pour être choisi
et puis ensuite pour défendre puisque
nous voulons absolument défendre mais
que puis-je faire
qui ne soit pas défavorable à sa défense
puisque c'est cela la question en
réalité je ne dois m'exposer
publiquement si je veux respecter votre
client qu'au service de sa défense et
donc c'est une vraie question et ensuite
savoir le faire vous savez quand vous
êtes un peu jeune sous cette pression
quand vous n'avez pas encore beaucoup
d'expérience est-ce que je vais savoir
faire ce qu'il convient de faire donc
pour mon rapport aux médias c'était
particulier puis pour mon rapport aux
clients là c'est la situation
particulière qui vous unit
quelqu'un dont on vous dit que le
discernement n'est pas total
et pourtant je ne suis que le porteur de
parole de celui qui m'a désigné pour le
défendre
alors c'est difficile c'est difficile de
savoir si je suis exactement en phase
avec ce qu'il souhaiterait que je dise
pour lui alors je ne parle pas de lui
précisément pour ne pas parler de
dossier précisément dont je ne suis plus
le concept mais je veux dire d'une
manière générale voilà les questions qui
peuvent se poser d'autres questions se
sont posées dans l'affaire de votre
confrère maître Karim Achoui que vous
avez défendu qui a été condamné à 7 ans
de prison pour complicité d'évasion
avant d'être acquitté en 2010 ça a été
également cette affaire un jalon
important ce procès a-t-il été
l'occasion pour vous d'expliquer ce
qu'est votre métier parce que j'ai le
sentiment qu'il y a une incompréhension
et un malentendu profond sur le rôle de
la vodka pénaliste et sur la fonction
même du procès pénal oui dossier très
important peut-être pour moi la faire la
plus importante dans ma carrière dont je
suis le plus heureux j'avais défendu en
premier instance un garçon auquel on
reprochait la participation à l'évasion
d'Antonio Ferrara puisque c'était ce
procès là qui avait été acquitté et donc
j'ai défendu Karima Shui avec mes
confrères un appel
pourquoi c'était très important pour moi
parce que c'était l'occasion d'expliquer
ce qu'est notre métier et comment la
proximité que l'on reprochait à Karima
choui avec celui qui s'était finalement
évadé de la prison de Fresnes cette
proximité n'est pas forcément une
complicité bien sûr chacun le sait tout
le monde le dit les magistrats vous
disent dans les colloques mais bien sûr
que nous le savons bien mais quand même
c'est une proximité vous comprenez bien
qui dérange on reprochait à Karim Achoui
des visites en prison une proximité dans
le but lui disait-on de transmettre des
informations qui allaient permettre à la
réalisation du projet d'évasion qui
était nourri par toute une bande de bien
organisée il a été une finalité et je
pense que parce que on le défendant nous
avons réussi à expliquer à des jurés ce
que pouvait être cette position très
singulière de l'avocat pénaliste très
proche y compris physiquement
le criminel et cependant avec la
distance qui fait que l'avocat n'est pas
le complice de criminel vous avez été
l'avocat Christian Saint-Palais entre
autres du braqueur Red One Faïd de
l'ancien directeur de campagne de
Nicolas Sarkozy en 2012 Jérôme lavrieux
poursuivi on le sait dans l'affaire
Bygmalion du rappeur acteur Joey Starr
de Nabila ou encore dans un autre genre
d'Alexandre Benalla l'ex chargé de
mission de l'Elysée c'est pour le moins
éclectique qu'est-ce qui vous conduit à
accepter ou refuser un dossier
d'ailleurs vous arrive-t-il dans refuser
des dossiers
parce que pour moi c'était essentiel
nous sommes choisis et donc la première
question quand même vais-je savoir faire
ce que celui qui me choisit souhaite que
je fasse pour sa défense parce que
parfois nous avons des divergences et là
ce n'est pas tellement vous qui refusez
d'ailleurs c'est celui qui est venu vers
vous qui se dit là ce n'est pas trouvé
le bon pour faire ce à quoi j'aspirer ce
dont je rêvais après nous avons des
considérations très triviales
c'est-à-dire bien parfois on vient vous
voir et on vous dit je souhaite
absolument que vous plaignez pour moi à
telle date en septembre 2023 et vous
ouvrez assez classiquement votre agenda
et donc vous ne pouvez pas voyez et puis
pourquoi ne pas aborder aussi
le coût d'une défense puisque nous
parlons de mon métier c'est aussi un
coût pour celui qui choisit un avocat et
donc nous parlons argent mais il vous
arrive de le faire pro bono bien sûr
pénaliste vous savez d'abord nous sommes
parfois sollicités par ceux qui sont
poursuivis pour des escroqueries et
croyez moi ils savent très bien tromper
leur avocat parfois enlève lattant en
leur disant vous verrez mettre comme
vous êtes le meilleur je vous donnerai
ce qu'il y a lieu en contrepartie et
puis on se fait avoir on est le dernier
escroquet dedans mais plus sérieusement
d'abord nous avons une fidélité pour nos
anciens clients un client un jour un
client toujours
l'an passé vous vous êtes à la fois
retrouvé à défendre la famille du père
Amel assassinait en 2016 à
Saint-Étienne-du-Rouvray et à côté de
yassinata frères cadet oussamahata le
cerveau des attentats du 13 novembre et
pour lequel vous appelez dès
l'acquittement la question peut sembler
idiote mais comment passe-t-on dans le
même journée du bon de la défense à
celle de l'accusation il va de soi que
vous défendez des hommes et non leur
crime mais cette facétie du calendrier
ne vous est-elle pas contraint malgré
tout à une certaine forme de
dissociation
alors la question je vais vous dire est
très importante et nous pour nous c'est
une question assez fondamentale je ne
vous cache pas que lorsque les
calendriers se sont télescopés et que
j'ai été convoqué pour les assises de ce
qui était ceux qui ont reproché la
participation au meurtre du paramètres
j'étais déjà impliqué dans le Bataclan
et la question que je me suis posée
c'est vrai ceux qui m'ont accordé leur
confiance vont-ils accepter que je passe
d'une salle à l'autre puisque géographie
comment c'est ce que je faisais je
passais d'une salle à l'autre pour
quitter le banc de la défense d'une
salle et rejoindre celui des parties
civils dans l'autre et donc la question
je la comprends puis je fais la
confiance à cet homme qui dans l'autre
salle plaide pour l'acquittement d'un
homme poursuivi pour terrorisme
et bien ils ont eu l'intelligence de
comprendre que évidemment tout ça
n'était pas impossible ce n'est pas
simple mais il faut dans la carrière
d'un avocat et c'est pour ça que je
pense qu'il faut que nous mesurions
toujours à vos capénalistes notre parole
publique il faut de la cohérence j'ai
l'impression que je défends l'état des
droits de la même façon quand je suis
sur le banc de la défense au procès du
Bataclan que sur les bancs des
participes dans le procès Amel une
question sur la défense cosmito vous
êtes le conseil de Jean-Jacques Bourdin
il est beaucoup question ces temps-ci de
prescription principe que vous défendez
ardemment vous savez bien que la
prescription est devenue le symbole de
l'injustice par excellence beaucoup et
voit la négation pure et simple des
actes dénoncés des souffrances en durée
qu'avez-vous envie de leur répondre à
ces victimes qui ont besoin d'être
entendus je comprends qu'elles ont
besoin d'être entendues mais d'abord
nous avons une législation nous avons
une loi mais qui n'a pas été adoptée à
la sauvette nous avons fixé des règles
nous avons beaucoup parlé les délais de
prescription mais depuis les années 90
je vous assure nous réfléchissons
collectivement
sur la possibilité d'allonger les délais
de prescription c'est-à-dire de
poursuivre plus tard les agressions
écrits sexuelles quand nous adoptons des
lois c'est après des réflexions qui
réunissent tous les professionnels des
avocats des magistrats des psychologues
des associations de victimes et nous
avons tous dit par la loi que certes
nous allions étendre mais que quand même
il y avait une limite c'est parce que
nous savons que nous ne pouvons pas bien
juger au terme d'un certain délai et que
parfois
la réponse judiciaire qui est de dire je
ne peux pas condamner cet homme qui est
mise en cause et donc je le relaxe où je
la quitte et très violente pour celle ou
celui qui a mené le parcours de
plaignant visant à obtenir la
condamnation dont nous disons ce n'est
pas cela qui va vous réparer et ça n'est
pas non plus méprisé vous voyez ça n'est
pas méprisé un plaignant que de lui dire
notre loi ne permet plus de faire les
choses ce à quoi il faut penser vous
savez j'ai été aussi dans mon parcours
vous le disiez instituteur je pense que
voilà la meilleure occasion le bon
moment l'école primaire le collège la
formation pour dire voilà comment vous
devez identifier les agressions
sexuelles sur votre corps et il faut que
nous arrivions à ce que c'est
révélations se fasse plutôt moi je ne
dis pas elle n'avait qu'à le faire
plutôt comme on l'a entendu de
philosophe pour laquelle nous avons oui
mais je ne parle pas aussi cruellement
parce que le propos était excessivement
d'après moi
bien sûr je sais très bien cette
difficulté à dire les choses à révéler
un viol ou une agression mais c'est pour
ça que nous devons travailler
et il faut un libération de la parole à
la libération de la parole à la
meilleure écoute ensuite mais d'abord la
libération de la parole beaucoup de vos
confrères font le lien entre démocratie
et défense pénales l'avocat c'est un
maillon essentiel de la démocratie c'est
celui qui met le pied dans la porte
oui alors je crois que vous savez la
machine judiciaire c'est une machine
étatique il y a des pouvoirs
considérables c'est légitime on veut
découvrir les auteurs d'infraction ce
qui ont violé la loi et par conséquent
on est doté de moyens extraordinaires
pour rentrer dans votre vie privée vous
placez sur écoute vous perquisitionnez
et cette machine est bien rodée pour que
des hommes et des femmes qui sont les
juges compétents prennent le relais de
la police et ensuite organise un procès
et le procès en principe il est pour
juger celui qui est dans le box dans
l'accusation est persuadée qu'il est
coupable et les choses doivent rouler
jusqu'au bout jusqu'à la condamnation
donc l'avocat il est là porteur
simplement d'un petit intérêt personnel
particulier et donc il faut avoir
conscience et bien sûr que cette machine
elle est puissante dotée des moyens de
l'État elle peut broyer et donc il faut
essayer de s'immiscer alors un avocat
pénaliste ne doit jamais être trop poli
avocat pénaliste doit
voler un peu sa place voyez ne l'est pas
immédiatement donné il doit la prendre
c'est ça aussi l'expérience de respecter
la règle mais cependant de se lever et
donc de faire vivre des règles qui
parfois peuvent être oubliées par
préoccupation d'efficacité et voyez ce
que vous évoquez tout à l'heure mais les
victimes alors est-ce que ça ne serait
pas les mépriser que de laisser trop de
place à la défense que de ne pas donner
satisfaction à ce qui a généré autant
d'émotions non l'avocat il est là pour
rappeler les principes et dire combien
c'est fondamental de faire bénéficier du
doute par exemple d'offrir du temps un
temps nécessaire à la défense c'est un
des problèmes que nous avions par
exemple pour procédé Bataclan beaucoup
de victimes équivalent parler mais les
hommes qui vont être jugés doivent aussi
pouvoir s'exprimer et là on retrouve le
barreau très souvent unis pour ce
respect des principes pourquoi parce que
nous savons que
ça n'est pas pour défendre les
puisque certains regardent ceux qui sont
dans le box comme des c'est pour
nous défendre nous citoyens citoyens au
quotidien qui pouvons être un jour mis
en cause dans des procédures et nous
serons bien heureux qui étaient
préservés ces principes qui nous
permettent de nous défendre mettre Saint
Palais on assiste à la fin du jury
populaire nos concitoyens n'ont plus
confiance leur justice ils ne pourront
bientôt plus y participer vous le
déplorez je le regrette mais très
profondément d'abord cette étonna qui
révolutionnaire symboliquement pour moi
c'est très important et puis vous savez
que nous nous peignons beaucoup
actuellement de la distance que prennent
nos concitoyens avec la justice de cette
méfiance et même défiance avec la
croissance le fait que les jurés
viennent participer à la justice et bien
ça permettait aux citoyens de se
rapprocher de cette justice de rentrer
chez eux et de dire vraiment il y a des
magistrats je peux vous dire et mouilles
la chemise et donc ça ça nourrit le
respect à la Garden institution
judiciaire et la complexité de la
décision judiciaire alors justement dans
son ouvrage de la démocratie en Amérique
Alexis Tocqueville n'était que le jury
sert à donner à l'esprit de tous les
citoyens une partie des habitudes de
l'esprit du juge et ses habitudes sont
précisément celles qui préparent le
mieux le peuple à être libre autrement
dit c'est un instrument de citoyenneté
qui permet de s'approprier et de
trancher un problème en prenant
conscience des difficultés inhérentes à
l'acte de jugé absolument et je pense
que si pour ce fait des jurés enfin si
on lit des témoignages de juré vous
voyez comme il se disent sorti enrichi
d'une telle expérience et c'est ça qui
est formidable pour moi c'est que ils
vont réintégrer notre groupe social
notre État de droit en sachant qu'on ne
peut pas porter un jugement trop rapide
sur celui qui est mis en cause d'abord
parce que ce n'est pas parce qu'il est
mis en cause ont-ils compris qu'il est
forcément coupable et ce n'est pas non
plus parce qu'il est mis en cause et
coupable d'un acte monstrueux que
lui-même ne révèle pas une part
d'humanité et qu'il ne mérite pas qu'on
s'approche de lui pour comprendre le
passage donc ça c'est très important on
a le sentiment au fond la justice est
bradée sur l'Hôtel du rendement une
logique de marché de de flux tendu
il y a un grand stock c'est un mot qui
est beaucoup plus utilisé la
Chancellerie le stock des dossiers il
faut résorber le stock des dossiers oui
il est difficile de réunir une cour
d'assise composée de jurer parce qu'il
faut convoquer les jurés il faut avoir
les salles nécessaires et donc cela peut
prendre du temps donc on aurait pu dire
mais on va doter davantage ce poste là
et on va multiplier les cours d'assises
avec les jurés on a dit non on va
économiser en réalité et on a dit on va
désormais juger comme en correctionnel
comme les délits de crime en supprimant
les jurés et en composant aujourd'hui de
5 magistrats professionnels vous verrez
je vous annonce aussi que dans quelques
années
bien sûr quand on a créé la cour
d'assise spéciale pour les terrorisme on
nous a dit on supprime les jurés parce
que vraiment les jurés ont trop peur
maintenant les jours ils n'ont pas peur
les jurés ont une mission citoyenne à
remplir et pouvait nous rejoindre pour
juger les crimes terroristes on a dit on
va vous mettre cette magistrats vous
voyez vous n'allez pas vous plaindre il
y a vraiment une grande spécialité mais
quelques années plus tard parce que
c'était trop cher nous n'avons plus que
5 et nous avons désormais cinq
magistrats donc aujourd'hui à la
concrétienne le départementale vous
allez magistrats il y en aura trois dans
quelques années oui nous avons un
problème de finance oui un effort
considérable avec une augmentation de 8
% du budget a été réalisé cette année
mais on n'a pas forcément affecté
l'argent là où on aurait pu l'affecter
et nous aurons les problèmes pour
meubler la cour criminelle le
départementale d'après moi très
rapidement parce que nous n'avons pas de
magistrats vous savez il faut trouver
des magistrats donc on vous dit nous
prendrons des avocats honoraires des
petits allées la justice sera bien
rendue attention
j'ai toujours dit que les magistrats
savent faire et donc les magistrats
rendront la justice et je ne prétends
pas qu'ils vont condamner davantage
d'innocents que l'aurait fait un jury
populaire mais nous perdons en solennité
nous perdons un adhésion du peuple au
rendu de la justice et ça c'est une
perte absolument considérable il faut
pas non plus se cacher la réalité vous
savez qu'il y a des mouvements qui
militent depuis longtemps pour la
suppression du jury populaire
et sans doute au barreau d'ailleurs
beaucoup d'éléments qui vous disent
enfin comment ces gens peuvent-ils juger
faut pas négliger ce regard extrêmement
méprisant qui est porté d'ailleurs les
magistrats après tout ils se disent j'ai
eu une formation très particulière
difficile des concours élitistes pendant
des années et donc des types au hasard
vont pouvoir remplir la même mission que
moi
spontanément sans aucune formation c'est
peut-être pour certains une question
assez insoluble mais il y a en tout cas
ce mouvement qui existe depuis longtemps
de supprimer finalement le peuple et
restons entre nous et je dis qu'entre
nous pas simplement la magistrats la
magistrat et certains membres du Barreau
qui se disent c'est une réforme
finalement pas si compliqué que ça et
vous avez vu que c'est un très grand
avocat pénaliste qui la porte désormais
cette réforme c'est pour ça que regardez
ça c'est pour ça que c'est très
douloureux pour moi parce que ça je
n'aurais jamais imaginé je savais bien
qu'il ne pourrait pas renverser la table
puisque cette réforme était déjà lancée
mais je n'imaginais pas qu'il allait
accélérer le mouvement et finalement
signer l'arrêt de mort de la Cour
d'Assise puisqu'à terre
vous vivez cela comme une trahison
pour lequel j'ai une admiration immense
parce que je conseille accepte un des
plus grands avocats du 20e siècle et je
suis tellement reconnaissant pour tout
ce qu'il a apporté à la défense mais
vous jugez cette réforme attentatoire
aux droits des citoyens bien sûr je la
trouve en tout cas attentatoire à l'état
de droit au principe de la démocratie la
participation des citoyens et que
n'avocat pénaliste qui a autant
fréquenté la cour d'assise
mais je constate les dégâts que peuvent
faire une carrière politique sur la
force des convictions une dernière
question mettre vous arpenter paraît-il
beaucoup les allées des cimetières
notamment celui de Montparnasse la
fréquentation des morts inspire vos
plaidoiries nourrissent vos réflexions
non je ne dirais pas cela mais quand
vous êtes fils de paysan je crois que
vous restez toujours fils de paysan nous
nous savons nous sommes nés et nous
savons
absolument et dans le cimetière c'est un
lieu que nous fréquentons beaucoup donc
c'est vrai que j'y retrouve le calme ses
propices à la méditation et puis ils
sont enterrés notamment à Montparnasse
de très grandes figures alors oui j'aime
cette confrontation silencieuse avec des
très grandes figures je ne prétendrai
pas qu'elle me nourrisse mais elle
permette à moi de m'apaiser et d'y
trouver les moments de méditation
nécessaire pour entrer ensuite dans
l'arène judiciaire merci merci à vous